RAY CROMWELL: Good afternoon.
How you guys doing?
I'm looking around the room and
I'm seeing a lot of people
who I think are either
passionate about GWT or Dart,
because you could have been
downstairs getting your Nexus
7, your Galaxy Nexus, and
your Nexus Q, but
you're here in my session.
So thanks for coming.
This session is titled
"Migrating Code from GWT to
Dart." And if you
might notice--
I'm tech lead for GWT.
My name is Ray Cromwell.
So the first thing you might be
asking-- and I get this a
lot-- before the session even
starts, is why Dart?
Why am I even giving a Dart
session in the first place?
I'm tech lead on GWT.
Well first of all, actually,
I think Dart's
a really cool language.
And I'm a compiler geek so I
tend to like languages and
language-oriented stuff.
So I volunteered to give this
session, because to me,
learning programming languages
is not about discussing which
language is best, whether Dart
is better than JavaScript or
better than Java and so on.
Because every language that you
encounter has things that
are good about them and
things that people
will complain about.
And so for each type of
application, there's always
sort of a sweet spot, and Dart
is no exception to that.
But it is a very cool language,
and it takes some of
the best features from
JavaScript and Java and
combines them into one.
And I'll get to that later.
I also think learning
new languages is
good for your brain.
Just like bilingualism and
spoken languages, if you learn
multiple programming languages,
it's going to be
good for your career.
It's going to make you think
in different ways.
And hopefully exposure to Dart
will make you think about
designing web applications in
different ways, perhaps ways
that are more structured, if
you're not a Java programmer.
And finally, I don't really
think that you can evaluate a
language unless you've
developed using it.
A lot of times, you're online
and you'll see people having
wars over programming
languages.
My language is better
than yours.
They'll microcriticize various
parts of the spec.
But really, you'll never know
what's cool about a language
or what sucks about it unless
you actually develop with it.
And so this presentation is
designed to help you utilize
what you already know, which is
hopefully Java and GWT, and
get you up to speed on Dart as
fast as possible so you can
try that experiment
out for yourself.
And then you can make the
decision whether or not you
think Dart is a good language
for you or GWT is a good
language for you, or hand-coded
JavaScript's a good
language for you.
And so I want to try to map
concepts that you already know
from Java and GWT into Dart so
that you'll understand things
faster and quicker.
I want to try to teach you some
Dart idioms and to get
your feet wet in terms of
porting some existing GWT
application constructs
into Dart.
So what is Dart?
We say it's a structured
language for web applications.
But it's more than that, because
on the surface, it has
the appearance of
being Java-like.
But underneath it's a
dynamically typed language.
So what does that mean?
If you think of JavaScript--
it means that you can refer to
things on an object, fields or
invoke methods and so on,
regardless of what the
declared type is.
You might say it's a customer
object, but at run time you
can still refer to that object
as if it was a totally
different type.
The type doesn't restrict
you from shooting
yourself in the foot.
But Dart goes a little bit
further, because although you
can do that, you can also run,
optionally, your application
in checked mode.
And in checked mode, the
types do have meaning.
And you will get runtime errors
if you, for example,
try to access something on an
object or a class that wasn't
there in that type.
But in general, when you're
programing in Dart, unlike in
Java, you should treat the
types like annotation or
documentation for both people
reading the code and for
machines that are processing
it, like tools.
Dart's also a class-based
object-oriented programming language.
It's not a prototype-based
language.
It's not functional language.
It's class-based
object-oriented.
But because it has a type
system and it's
OO, it's very toolable.
So one of the things you'll be
able to do is you'll be able
to go out and get things like
the Dart Editor, which is
based on the Eclipse framework,
or the latest
IntelliJ plugin, and you'll
actually be able to get all of
this nice stuff that you
like in Java in Dart.
Command method completion, field
completion, refactoring,
go to declaration--
all those things are there.
Things that are actually
typically hard to do in
dynamic languages with
IDEs, you can do
quite easily with Dart.
And Dart has the option of
running either natively in the
Dart VM or in any other browser
by using a Dart-to-JS
compiler, which compiles
the JS just like GWT.
So let's dive right in.
Rather than teaching the
language spec, if you haven't
seen any of the other sessions,
I'm just going to
start off with Java and try to
transmorgify it into Dart.
Let's see how that works out.
So the first thing that's
different between Dart and
Java is basically, there's no
access modifier keywords.
So you can basically just remove
the private and public
declarations and the code
will continue to work.
The next thing is that
types are optional.
So it's not-- we don't always
recommend removing types.
I think well-written library
code should have the types
there so when other people are
reading your code, they'll
actually kind of know
the intent.
But just to show you, we
can remove that string
declaration, that Boolean field
declaration, and we end
up with that.
The other thing is that--
and I actually like
this feature.
This is one of my favorite
features of Dart.
In Java, you write the same code
over and over and over
again for initializing
constructors.
You have a constructor.
It takes three parameters.
What is the first thing you
do in the body of the
constructor?
This dot x equals y, this dot a
equals b, and so on, right?
The same thing--
and a lot of languages have
this problem too, but Dart
actually has a little bit of
syntactic sugar for this.
So if you want to auto-assign
a parameter to a field, then
you refer to the field in the
constructor parameter
declaration with a
this qualifier.
So here I'm saying this.name
and that's it, in the
constructor parameter list.
And basically the Dart VM or the
Dart compiler knows that
that refers to the field name,
which has a string type, and
it's going to autogenerate
this.name equals name for you.
In Java, if you have a block of
code in an if statement or
a for statement that only has
one line, you now that you can
eliminate the curly braces
and just put a semicolon.
In Dart, even for method
declarations, you can
eliminate the curly braces.
So here is a method that only
has one line of code in it.
And so the cat constructor just
equals greater-than and
then an expression to
the right of it.
So Dart doesn't have packages.
It has something that's not
exactly like a package.
It's called a library.
And so here we just delete
package com.foo and we just
use #library('foo'), which is
basically saying the code
below it is part of
that library.
Now I said that Dart doesn't
have access qualifiers, like
public and private.
But you can hide things
within a library.
So you can make it so that no
one outside of the library foo
can see a particular variable.
And the way you do that is by
putting a leading underscore
on the field name.
So in this example, _name and
_iCanHazMeme are only visible
to classes within
the library foo.
So Dart doesn't have an import
statement like Java, but it
does have #import.
And with #import, basically,
you import libraries.
And this is the syntax for it.
So we're getting there.
We're almost fully converted.
So Dart has final fields,
but they're initialized
differently than Java.
They're using the C++-style
initializer list.
So if you have some final
fields, they have to be
assigned during construction.
And so the way you do it is
you put a colon after the
constructor and then a
comma-separated list of
assignments.
Dart also has static fields.
So you can see in this example,
UBER_CAT, we want it
be a static, final, immutable
Cat, right,
that everyone sees.
And you can initialize them to
be immutable or singleton--
think of string interning
in Java--
by using something Dart has
called a const constructor.
So if you put the const keyword
in front of the Cat
constructor, essentially what
this is saying is that there's
only ever one instance of that
Cat with that parameter name.
So if you construct a Cat and
the name is Mr. Tibbles, then
there's only one instance
of Mr. Tibbles.
And the next time you try to
allocate one, you'll still get
the same instance.
That means you can
use a reference
comparison, for example.
Another biggie, and this'll
probably be the biggest shock
if you're coming from Java or
GWT, is that there's no
function overloading in Dart.
And so here's a typical
example of Java--
the Money class, where it's
storing things as a
fixed-point integer.
Let's say multiplied by 100,
so it's in pennies.
And so someone might have
three constructors.
One that takes an int, one that
takes a string, and one
that takes a double.
And they might have some
overloaded methods.
So down at the bottom we
have two add methods.
One takes another Money class,
and one takes another Money
class but optionally charges tax
before it adds the money.
So Dart works around this
problem by introducing named
constructors.
So in Dart, your constructor
does not always have to have
the same name as your
class itself.
In Java, your constructor
for the Cat class is
always called Cat.
In Dart, you have a
constructor called
Money.fromDouble and
Money.fromString.
So the actual qualified
constructor name is itself an
constructor.
So someone, if they wanted to
create Money from a double,
they'd say new Money.fromDouble
and then the value.
Likewise, for the overloaded
method case, what we can do is
we can collapse those two
methods into a single method
because Dart has optional
parameters.
So all you do to make a
parameter optional is you
enclose it in square brackets.
So now the original Money
class, which had two
parameters, and then another
specialized version, which had
the emitted parameter is
collapsed into a single method
which has the optional
parameter.
And you could specify default
values for the parameters.
So typically in Java, if you
have this case where you have
two overloads, and one of them
is just an overload because
you want to allow the person to
emit an optional parameter,
you'd typically have one method
call the other and pass
in the default value.
Here you can just specify
the value.
So I say in the default,
if you don't specify
chargeTax is true.
The government's gonna
love that.
As a bonus, all optional
parameters are named
parameters.
So if you have a list of like
five optional parameters, and
maybe you don't memorize the API
but you happen to know the
names of the parameters, you
can specify the optional
parameter by putting a colon
in front of its name.
So I'm passing the chargeTax
parameter by
saying chargeTax: false.
Here's an interesting thing.
A lot of people complain about
Java, of people creating tons
of factory service locator,
factory factory classes, and
things like that.
And factories and dependency
injection are very, very
common in Java.
And I think Dart recognized
this and said, we should
provide a solution for
this that doesn't
add a lot of bloat.
And so what you can do is you
can designate a constructor as
a factory constructor.
So here we're saying the Money
constructor that takes an
amount is a factory
constructor.
And what it does is it says,
if the amount is equal to
zero, then return this static
final interned instance of
zero, else return a new
Money object that's
constructed on the fly.
And typically you might do this
if you want to use zero
as a special value to use
reference equality.
There's only ever one Money
object representing zero
money, but other ones actually
have differing values.
And so what happens is, when
you new the Money object it
actually calls this method, and
the method actually can
return a different object,
unlike a typical Java
constructor.
You can't return something from
the constructor that's
different than the
object itself.
And Dart also has operator
overloading.
So we can make that Money class
a little easier to use
by overwriting operator+
on it.
And now you can just say
money+money instead of
money.add(money).
And finally, Dart has
getters and setters.
So this is a typical
POJO, Plain Old Job
Object bean, in Java.
And so we have a field called
Amount, so naturally we have
to write an int get amount that
returns _amount, and a
setter for it.
And then on the bottom, you
see method calls from it.
Whereas in Dart, what you can
do is you can put a get
keyword in front of the function
name and a set
keyword in front
of the setter.
And then what happens is you can
reference the object as if
those were field references,
not method calls.
And Dart will actually invoke
the getter methods for you.
So this is kind of a less
boilerplate-y way of setting
up fields with getters and
setters or properties.
Let's talk about the type
system differences.
So there's really only five
built-in types you need to
worry about.
There are two numeric types.
There's int and double.
And yes, you're reading
that right.
The integer is infinite
precision, so you never have
to worry about overflow
in your code.
If you want to compute--
boy, don't try to compute
Google because
you'll run out of memory.
But if you want to compute a
very large number, you can use
integers to do it.
Doubles are 64-bit IEEE-754
goodness.
Typically you might have a
game or a lot of math or
physics code, and they're
great to use for that.
Dart does have a String.
Class It has a bool type--
not Boolean, but bool.
And it has two fundamental
collection types that
everybody uses, hopefully,
which is List and Map.
And like every other language
except for Java, they have
first-class support.
So there are literals
for maps and lists
built into the language.
So you define a List literal
with square brackets, and you
define a map with curly braces,
much like JSON and
JavaScript.
There's some big differences
with strings
between Java and Dart.
String support interpolation
in Dart-- so you can put a
dollar sign and then a variable
name inside of any
string, and Dart will substitute
that with the
variable of the same name that's
in the same scope.
But you can go a little
bit further, too.
You could put a curly brace.
And for example, you can invoke
a method call on that.
If this looks familiar to you,
it looks very much like the
expression language that's often
in many Java frameworks,
like JSP and JSS and things
like that, or like Apache
property substitution.
One of the features I love most,
actually, is heredocs,
and Dart was very good
to add that.
And it's basically multi-line
strings that you can include
verbatim in the code.
And that's really, really useful
if you want to bake in
some HTML or some CSS into your
app, and you don't have
to worry about going in and
escaping every new line and
all the other kind of stuff.
You can kind of structure
DSL-specific syntaxes right
into your Dart source code,
just by putting
in a multiline string.
And if you don't want
interpolation, because maybe
you want literal dollar signs,
just put an @ in front of the
string, and it turns it
off for that string.
I don't want to say a
lot about generics.
Dart does have generics, but
they are radically simplified
generics, which is
a good thing.
Because Java generics--
I mean, if anybody's played
around in Scala, this sounds
like somebody whining, but Java
generics are actually
kind of complicated, and a lot
of people don't understand the
difference between covariants,
invariants, contravariants,
wild cards, and things
like that.
And as a result, most people
don't even use those features.
I mean, if you're Joshua Bloch,
you use them in the
Java collections classes, but if
you go look at most regular
Java programmers, they
hardly ever use most
of these extra features.
And so Dart basically said,
why add all this extra
complexity?
Most people would just use
Foo if T So Dart only has
covariants for generics.
But Dart does not use erasure.
So generics in Dart are
actual reified.
You can check the
runtime types.
So a Foo or a list of int--
you can actually check
it to see what it is.
And if you try to say,
is this a foo of
string, it will say false.
That's not the case in Java,
where if you have a list of T,
a list of anything, basically
it's only really a list, and
you actually cannot check
what it is at runtime.
But in general, I would
say, don't worry
too much about this.
Things just kind of work, and
you don't have to worry too
much about it.
Generics in Dart are simple and
they work out of the box.
And don't get yourself worried
about what's being left out.
The other-- and I want to say
the third favorite feature of
mine is finally lexically
scoped closures.
I wish Java had them.
I wish Java 8 will have them.
Hopefully they will.
But yes.
Bye-bye, anonymous classes,
and hello function types.
So here is an example of
an apply function.
It takes a list of integers and
applies the function to
each thing in the list and
returns a new list.
And so at the bottom I just
show a simple example.
Apply an inline literal list of
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, a function
which basically doubles
its input.
So what you do to declare a
closure is you basically put
the parameters in parentheses
with optional types, and then
you put =>, and then the
expression to be evaluated,
the function body.
You can use curly braces
there too if you want.
And you can make things a
little bit more readable
because Dart has typedefs.
So often, these function
declarations, if they're
really complicated and take a
lot of parameters-- maybe have
a function which takes functions
to functions, and
things like that--
you want to break them down
into separate steps.
And with typedefs,
you can do that.
So here I'm basically saying
that there is a function that
takes an int and returns an int,
and I'm going to give it
the name Transformer.
And then my apply function
now, rather than saying--
if you look at the previous
slide, it's int f(int arg))
Now this says Transformer bay.
Maybe some of you get the
reference to that.
And so then at the bottom, I
have another one where I say
Transformer prime
= (x) => 2 * x.
And so it looks a little
more readable.
You can document the typedef
and things like that.
OK so that kind of covers the
language syntax case.
Now I'm going to cover just some
of the API differences.
So Dart has two collection
classes, as I mentioned
before, and they
are generified.
That's List and Map.
And so in Dart, you can create
them in two ways.
You can new them, with the new
operator, or you can construct
them inline with literals,
which a lot of people do.
That's a very common
thing to do.
And you don't actually have to
worry about the underlying
concrete types.
So Map and List will be abstract
classes and there
might be multiple
implementations of Map and
List, but Dart will
pick a default
implementation for you.
In Java, you have to think,
am I going to use HashMap?
Am I going to use
LinkedHashMap?
And things like that.
And then iteration--
you have multiple
choices, right?
So you can use what's called
external iteration, where you
basically have your own for
loop, you ask for the length
of the list, and you iterate
over it and you index into it
like an array, like List[i].
No operator overloading to
access list members.
You don't have to
say List.get(i).
Or you could use the
For In operators.
You could say for (value
in list) .
Or you can use an internal
iterator, which is basically,
you pass a closure to the
forEach method, and it will
loop over the collection
internally and call your
function for each member
of the list.
And then there's equivalent
methods for Map.
It's just that they take two
parameters for the forEach
method, key and value, or you
have to get the set of keys
and the set of values
to iterate over.
All right.
So now let's actually move on
to converting the actual GWT
code over to Dart.
And so let's first convert
a really simple example.
Here's a "Hello World" in GWT.
You have the onModuleLoad
function, and I'm going to
call window.alert("Hello
World").
What would this look
like in Dart?
Really, really compact.
So first thing is we import the
Dart HTML library so we
can get the window function,
the alert function.
Secondly, Dart's EntryPoint,
is the main function.
So--
whoops--
what?
There we go.
Let me restart.
I don't know why
that happened.
Let's go back.
I have a lot of slides.
OK.
There we go.
This one.
And so if you look at this, you
have to declare a class.
You have to implement
EntryPoint.
You have to have an onModuleLoad
function with
access qualifiers.
And then you call
window.alert.
Here you just declare a main
function and that basically
runs whatever code
is specified.
But a lot of times people are
going to structure a little
more, because you don't want
everything running in main.
So people might decide
to declare a class.
So here I have a class called
Hello, and my equivalent of
onModuleLoad is the
go function.
And from main, I just
create that Hello
instance and invoke go.
So this is a really important
point right now.
So you know, Dart is
bleeding edge.
And we're working hard on
it, and we're working
as fast as we can.
But we don't yet have a widget
library in the SDK that you
can download today.
One will be available soon.
If you've seen some of the other
demos, like the Swarm
app, there's some really
slick stuff going on.
And that knowledge will
translate into an awesome
widget library.
But for now, we just have
DOM programming.
And so I'm going to compare GWT
DOM program versus Dart
DOM programming.
So here is an example.
I might have a div tag with
ID "button" in the HTML.
So I'm going to add an
EventListener, a click
EventListener, to
that div tag.
And so here's the GWT
code that you have
to write to do that.
So you have to look it up by
going Document.get, which gets
the document element.
Then getElementByID
and the button.
Then you have to sink the event
type event you want to
listen to, so you use
DOM.sinkEvents.
Then you have to set the
EventListener callback,
DOM.setEventListener, and have
an anonymous inner class
callback with a function
declared in it, which then has
window.alert.
So what would that look
like in Dart?
You just say Query
("#ID").on.click.add and then
a closure for the
EventHandler.
Now there's a couple
of interesting
things going on here.
First of all, Dart has global
functions, and so not every
method has to be part
of a class.
So there's a global top-level
query function, and basically
it kind of acts like the
dollar-sign function in
jQuery, if you want to think
of it like that.
So I'm looking up the button
with ID "button." And I'm
going to get back an element.
Now the element going to have a
magic field in it called on.
And on is going to have a bunch
of setter properties--
like I showed you setters
earlier--
for each type of event.
So here we've got one
called click--
a setter.
We've got one called mouseOver
and things like that.
And each one of those is going
to have an add method on it.
And so now, I'm just saying--
for the element that I got back,
on click, give me back
this click thing, which can then
allow me to add a closure
to it, which will be called.
And so that's basically how you
would write the same code.
You look at it again--
it looks a lot more readable.
So that's basically converting
a Hello World and some simple
DOM programming.
This is kind of where
Dart is today.
As I said, there's high-level
libraries that are on the way
real soon now.
But for now, it's really an
HTML5 experience, which is not
always the worst thing.
But here's the sort of
high-level mapping of what API
in GWT corresponds to what
you have to do in Dart.
So if you're using
com.google.gwt.dom, you're
going to import the
dart:html library.
If you're using UIBinder and
SafeHTMLTemplates and
[INAUDIBLE] messages from GWT,
you're probably just going to
use Dart string interpolation
to do the same thing.
If you're doing server
communication, like GWT RPC or
Request Factory, in Dart, right
now, today, you're going
to use XMLHttpRequest.
For widgets, of course,
GWT has widgets.
For Dart, real soon now
there's going to
be some cool stuff.
And in multi-process, for using
WebWorkers, GWT has some
third-party hacks that add
WebWorker support to GWT.
Dart actually has WebWorkers
built in to the language as a
first-class construct.
They're called isolates.
And so doing multi-process stuff
within Dart really has
no equal anywhere.
They make it really
easy to use.
So let's try to get a little
more deeper and port something
more complex.
Let's try to port a widget.
Now widgets are written in many
different ways in GWT.
I'm just going to focus on the
modern way people do widgets
with GWT, which is
with UIBinder.
And so the idea here is just
how can I take a GWT widget
that I've written that uses
UIBinder to define its HTML
structure and port that
over to Dart?
And the general idea here is
just to take the UIBinder
template and enclose it in
a multi-line string.
Convert any of the ui:field
attributes to just be ID
attributes on the elements.
Then build a Dart class to
represent normally what GWT
would generate to bind that
template, which is basically
looking up the IDs and assigning
them to fields in
your object.
And then you'll have to
basically move the raw HTML
resources, like CssResource, to
be external CSS by using a
link tag to include the CSS.
It's not a perfect solution, but
it's not horribly bad to
port code like this.
So here's an example.
This is how it looks in Java.
I have a UIBinder template
with a div tag.
It says, Hello, <span ui:
field = 'nameSpan' /> .
And then here I have a little
bit of code which basically
calls setElement(UIBin
der.CreateandBindUi(this)).
Now if you're GWT programmer,
you know
this works some magic.
And what happens is, is it
basically generates some code
behind the scenes that will take
that UIBinder template,
create a div tag, and inject
that HTML source, as an inner
HTML, into it.
And put it into the document.
And then the next thing it will
do is it will go through
and it will look up
that field, that
UI field, the nameSpan.
And when it finds that element,
it will store it in
the field on your class.
You can see here, this
nameSpan attribute.
So this element will be looked
up in the DOM with
getElementById and then
put there for you.
So kind of like a dependency
injection.
So we want to get
that into Dart.
So how can we emulate that?
So the first thing is, we remove
the top and bottom XML
tags and replace them
with triple-quote.
And so now we've just put it
into a multi-line string.
And we replace the ui:field
with just id='nameSpan'.
And then secondly, the next step
that we'd do is we would
write a function--
that you can see right here--
which will first create a new
HTML element with the
template, which we
defined up here.
And what this new Element.html
does is it actually kind of
creates a div and injects the
string as the innerHTML of it.
So what you get back, basically,
is essentially what
UIBinder was doing as a div
element with the HTML in it.
And then once we get that, we
input it into the DOM, the
next thing we're going to do is
run element.query on it and
look up id nameSpan and then
assign it to the field
nameSpan here.
So GWT kind of automates that
part of it, which is
automatically looking up the
element for you and then
signing it.
So you actually have to write
that code yourself here, but
it's not too bad.
But you could make it
expandable, extensible.
So here I have one where we have
two nameSpan tags in my
template and I would have
two fields, like a
nameSpan1 and a nameSpan2.
Instead of having fields on my
object, I use a map, a map
from the id to the element.
And then what I do is I extend
my setElementByTemplate
function to take the template,
which was from up here, and
take a list of ids to look
up, which were up here.
And then what this is going to
do is it's going to inject
this and then document.query
look up each one of those and
inject them into
the map for me.
And that's what this basically
does here.
It loops over for each ID and
then it injects into the map,
calling element.query
with the id.
And so that's a way to sort
of make it extensible.
So you could have an arbitrary
number of elements that are
looked up and automatically
injected for you, so you can
cache them and look
them up later.
What about instantiated widgets,
though, right?
So I just showed you
HTML tags that
are in UIBinder templates.
But you know that GWT
does a lot more.
So for example, you might use
HTMLPanel, or Menu item, or
Tree item, and things
like that.
Well, if it's a basic leaf
widget in GWT, like an input,
or a checkbox, or a text area,
or something, you can just
replace those with the
HTML5 equivalents.
In fact for GWT, even, we
recommend actually not using
heavyweight widgets for stuff
that's just basic HTML5.
It's just too much overhead.
But if you have something like a
composite type that's really
complex, like a menu
or a tree--
yes, right now, you're going
to actually need to code
replacements.
The good news is you're only
going to do it once, but yeah,
you're going to have to write
your own tree for now.
And I expect that as Dart gets a
larger and larger community,
even if Dart provides its own
widget library, probably other
people are going to
write their own
widget libraries too.
Someone will have a fancy tree
or a fancy carousel widget or
something that is not included
in the library.
So for now, it's an HTML
experience, but things will
get better.
But if you think it's too hard
to port widgets, then there's
an alternate pattern that
you can use to get your
feet wet with Dart.
Let's say you have an existing
GWT application and you want
to kind of try out Dart.
Maybe you want to write
a new page.
You want to add a new page to
your application, like a
settings screen or like a
feedback page or something.
And you want to write that part
in Dart, but the entire
rest of the part, you
want to keep in GWT.
So you want to keep your
application running at all
times and not throw everything
away and start from scratch.
The good news is that if you use
the Activities and Places
model that's been in GWT for a
while, or if you've always
been using history tag routing,
then you could do
this quite easily.
And the way you could
do it is this.
You have your GWT application
look for history state changes
in the hashtag.
And if the history change is
one of the things that your
app understands, then route the
event to the existing GWT
code that's going to
put up that page.
But if it's something you don't
understand, then send a
message or let it fall through
to a Dart application that's
running in the same page.
So you've source-scripted in the
GWT module and you've also
source-scripted in your Dart
app, and they're both looking
at the history.
And if they agree not to step
on each other's toes, this
could work very well.
The Dart code could look at
it and go, well, I don't
understand that history tag, so
GWT can probably take care
of that one.
But I see one that's destined
for me, like the feedback
page, the new feedback page, so
I'm basically going to take
over the main content
area of the page and
replace it with my UI.
Right?
And so that gives you kind of a
very high-level integration
point for putting Dart pages
into your existing GWT apps.
You could migrate page
at a time that way.
Here's a picture, like you
might have a banking
application.
And so maybe you have an
existing bill payment service,
and #billpay on the URL will
send you to the bill pay
activity in the GWT app.
But you're adding a new page,
which is banking, like maybe
bank transfers.
And so you've written
that one in Dart.
So what you do is you just have
the Dart part of the app
that's sitting in the page look
for #banking in the URL.
And that's the signal for it
to actually take over the
content area and install
its view.
But if you do this, the very
next thing you're going to run
into is, how do you share
application state?
I mean, maybe the GWT app just
did something and now the Dart
app actually has to get
what was changed.
And so there are a number
of options for this.
One option is, use
browser storage.
So you could use IndexDB,
SessionStorage, or cookies and
have GWT commit transient
session-oriented data, let's
say the current account or
profile representing the user.
Have it committed to IndexDB
storage in the browser.
And then when Dart goes to kick
off its view, like you
navigate to the banking page,
then it's going to read from
the database and get things
related to the user, like his
name, his current account,
authentication tokens to let
him make transfers, and
things like that.
The other option is, you could
put serialized data objects
into the DOM.
So if you want Dart to pick up
something that GWT has to send
to it, one option is just create
an element, like a div
element, use display none, and
put some data in there.
And then give it an
id, like an id =
data object or something.
And then just have Dart
look it up and parse
the JSON out of it.
That's another option.
Probably the cleanest mechanism
is just to use messaging.
So in the new HTML5 browsers.
you have window.postMessage().
So you can use this
for communication
between GWT and Dart.
Have Dart listen on window
object for messages and just
have GWT post messages, so you
can transfer data back and
forth between the two running
apps that way.
So one thing, as a GWT
programmer, you're probably
wondering about is something
like JSNI.
And we got a lot of mileage
out of that with GWT.
Early on in GWT's adoption,
there were a lot of JavaScript
libraries out there.
We didn't have really
killer widgets.
GWT widgets really looked
terrible out of the box.
And so people we're going and
picking up jQuery or picking
up Ext JS and things like
that and they were
wrapping them with GWT.
And that really held people over
until we could actually
deliver better widgets
in later versions.
And so you might be thinking,
well I'll do that for Dart.
I'll use Dart and I'll wrap some
cool widgets until the
Dart team delivers the
better widget set.
Unfortunately, Dart does
not have JSNI.
And there's a very good
reason for that.
And so you might think of
Dart as it is today as
a Dart-to-JS compiler.
But Dart as it's envisioned is
actually a virtual machine
that runs just like V8 does,
but it runs Dart code.
And so because it's another
virtual machine in the
browser, it's separate
from V8.
It has a separate heap.
So you can't just pass an object
reference from one to
the other, because they live
in different memory spaces.
Probably even different
process sandboxes.
So that wouldn't be very
efficient, even if you could
pull it off.
But there still is a need for
you to make calls from Dart to
JavaScript and vice versa.
There's no question
about that.
There is a need to do that.
Like, you might want to interact
with the Maps API
from Google, and there's
no Dart Maps API yet.
And so there has to be
a way to do this.
And fortunately, there
is a way to do it.
There's an unofficial way--
quite a few, actually, which
I'm going to show you.
And I'm going to make you a
promise that we're actually
working on it, and actually, a
real nice solution will be
coming later down the pipe.
So what are the ways
we can do this?
Well one way is this
postMessage() communication,
like I just discussed.
So what you could do is you
could have JavaScript listen
for window.onmessage, and
anything that basically comes
in through a message, you
just run eval on it.
And then likewise, in
the Dart world--
this is Dart code here--
you do postMessage, and in
there you put JavaScript.
And then so the JavaScript event
handler gets triggered
and it just runs eval.
So I've made a call from Dart
to JavaScript in that way.
It's not pretty, but it works.
Another solution that people do,
because you have a little
bit more control, is script
tag injections.
So in Dart code, you could just
create a script tag, set
its text attribute to be the
JavaScript text, and insert it
into the body of the browser
document, and it
will just be evaluated.
But that's only uni-directional
communication,
and you can't build an API if
you can't get any values back
after you evaluate the code.
You could have bi-directional
messaging.
So I could send the message to
JavaScript, and it'll say,
call this method on Google
Maps for me.
Google Maps dot
setCurrentLongitude = 10.
But the problem is, I can't get
any return value from that
function back.
You could make the JavaScript
then post the message back to
Dart and have Dart listen for a
message, which then has the
return value in it.
And in that case, it would
look very much like
asynchronous JSON-RPC back and
forth between the server.
But the API that could be built
around that would look
pretty nasty.
For example, every getter and
setter would have to take a
closure that would be called
back into with the return
value when it was ready.
You have got to remember,
the browser isn't always
synchronous.
So if you ask the browser to do
something, it could do it
immediately, or actually,
it could do it
at next event loop.
And so you have to basically
pass it a callback because it
could be executed
at a later time.
And so this would lead to a
really poor API experience.
But it turns out, there's
actually an API in a browser.
It's one of the very few
synchronous XHRs or another
that actually is synchronous,
meaning it actually blocks
until it finishes executing.
And it's called dispatchEvent().
And what it allows you to do is
to fire off an event, like
onClick or something like that,
and it will be handled
immediately.
Not the next time the browser
goes to the event loop, or
after all the set timeouts
run, but right now.
And so that gives us a hack or
sort of a doorway to get true
synchronous bi-directional
messaging between Dart and
JavaScript.
And the essential way you'll
do it is this.
You're going to invent a
new custom event name.
And you can do that
in JavaScript.
You can make your own events.
You don't have to just use
onClick or mouseover.
And I'll call it 'dartjsni',
just for GWT'S sake.
And then what you're going to do
is you're going to register
an event listener in Dart via
window.addEventListener and
look for this 'dartjsni' event
to happen, and do something
when it does happen.
And then you're going to
construct a serialization
format for RPC calls.
Maybe you just take the method
name and all the arguments
that you want to call and you
serialize them in a JSON
object or something.
And you have the callback
that's looking for that
'dartjsni' event deserialize
it and evaluate it.
Then you're going to invent
another event name-- let's
call it 'returnjsni'--
and it's going to take the
return value, serialize it,
and then fire via
window.dispatchEvent this
'returnjsni' event.
And then in the Dart code,
you're going to be looking for
window.OnDartjsni event handler,
and that's going to
be the return value.
And what makes this all work
is that when both sides use
dispatchEvent(), there
is no asynchronicity.
You fire the event and it
immediately evokes the
callback on the JavaScript
side.
The JavaScript side does the
evaluation and invokes
dispatchEvent for 'returnjsni'
and it immediately runs the
Dart event handler, all in
one synchronous loop.
This is just a picture of it.
It's probably not very
useful for you.
But I tried to draw
how it would work.
I'm just going to skip
that picture for now.
So you could make the
JSNI mappings even
more natural, right?
Like what if you just wanted
to have a Dart object, and
when you refer on that Dart
object to any field or any
method, it actually is kind of
a mirror or a proxy directly
into JavaScript.
It kind of represents a
JavaScript object on the other
side of the fence.
And so Dart has two features
that actually almost make this
look completely natural and
almost like the JavaScript's
not even involved.
The first is operator
overloading.
So you can implement
the operator[]--
and here I have a class
called JsProxy--
and it takes a field name.
And then what you do is you
make that synchronous call
over using that Dart
JSNI method I just
described how you'd do.
And you index the field name on
the object reference that
you're holding on to, that this
proxy object represents.
Dart has another feature I
haven't described yet.
Because it's a dynamic language,
what I said earlier
was is that you can try to
access or invoke anything on
an object, even though it's the
wrong type, and it will
still try it.
And if it fails, it doesn't
fail completely.
What it does is it invokes
noSuchMethod.
So it's a magical method.
You could put it on a Dart class
to override it, and it
will be called for any method
that it can't find, that
someone tried to invoke.
And so in this way, you could
make a JsProxy class that can
invoke any JavaScript method
that exists in the JSVM by
defining a noSuchMethod.
It takes the name of the method
someone's trying to
invoke and a list of the
arguments, and then you just
make a synchronous call using
what I just described in the
previous slide.
And it will return the value as
if that method existed on
the JsProxy object by going to
JavaScript and asking it to
evaluate it.
So that's another interesting
idiom or
example you could use.
And if you wanted to invoke GWT
code directly from Dart or
vice versa, I would advocate
using a library I wrote called
GWT Exporter.
And what that allows you to do
is to put @Export annotations
on your classes and
Java methods.
And what it does is it manually
declares JavaScript
exports in the top-level window
object of the page.
And then once you've got those
things exposed to JavaScript,
then you can use the Dart JSNI
method technique I showed you
to just call directly
into GWT.
Likewise, if you wanted to do
it the other way around, you
could export Dart functions into
JavaScript by writing a
JavaScript function which, when
invoked, uses the Dart
JSNI mechanism to send a message
over to Dart and say,
I'm invoking this method
on this Dart class.
However what I've just shown
you, it's really complicated
and it's kind of a hack.
And I would not advocate using
it, except for specialized
scenarios like trying to create
a really nice mapping
for, like, the Google Maps
library or some other
JavaScript library, where it
would be painful to have an
asynchronous approach.
Otherwise, I would suggest,
just use postMessage.
It's the easiest thing and
the least likely to fail.
And for the record, we actually
don't know how much
longer dispatch will
be around.
It could very well be that the
HTML5 committee could say
tomorrow, we're removing that.
So in summary I just wanted to
say that Dart is a cool new
dynamic language.
It takes some of the best things
from JavaScript, which
is the ability to start up
quickly without a compile
pass, to have the program
run even though
the types are wrong.
So you can iterate on
something, even
if you've got errors.
But also to allow the language
to be tooled and tested with
compile-time static
tool chains.
It offers a lightweight DOM
programming library for now,
but later on, it will have
a very rich library.
That's the whole point of
having a structured
programming language.
They invented all of this new
syntax for a type system.
They're going to build
a really rich
library to support it.
It's not going to be very raw
and basic like JavaScript.
Try converting some simple
GWT libraries.
Get your feet wet.
Pick the simplest thing in your
project and say, what
would this look like in Dart?
Just play around with it.
Have some fun.
Or integrate--
try to add a new page your app
by basically writing it in
Dart and using the hashtag
history routing to integrate
it into the page.
I would advocate, even if you're
not going to use Dart,
to look at the GWT Activities
and Places model if you're not
using it already.
Because it will help
you in the future.
And finally, if you're really
adventurous, try hacking a
Dart JSNI library.
You could probably release it,
and if you do it quick enough,
everyone might use it.
So that's my presentation.
Hope you guys got something
out of it.
And I'm open to taking
some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You mentioned
internationalization and
string interpolation.
RAY CROMWELL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I wonder, do you have
an example of that, like
how it works in Dart?
I'm using it in GWT, but to
migrate some stuff, I'm going
to need to move it do Dart.
RAY CROMWELL: Yeah, that's
a good question for me.
[INAUDIBLE], do you happen
to know the idiom for
doing that in Dart?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RAY CROMWELL: What I was
thinking of, when I wrote
that, was basically using the
string interpolation to define
the templates like you would do
it in a Messages class in
GWT and basically create the
equivalent of a Dart
ResourceBundle but using
JSON structures.
And then write in a little
utility library to basically
perform the equivalent of what
gets code generated in GWT,
which is to take the template
and basically apply the JSON
to it to fill out
the template.
Yeah, sorry.
I probably should have fleshed
that out more.
I probably ran out of time,
doing my slides.
AUDIENCE: That's fine.
And I'm looking for something a
little bit more formal with
the Places and Activities.
Is there something like
that planned for Dart?
Or is it just like window.on
listening
for that native event?
RAY CROMWELL: Yeah I don't
know the answer to that.
But I believe the Dart team is
working on rich object models.
And they're probably looking
at MBC or MBP.
Do you happen to know, Vijay?
VIJAY:MENON: [INAUDIBLE]
RAY CROMWELL: So just in case no
one heard that, they built
a really nice application
called Swarm.
And what they're doing is
they're taking the lessons
learned from building that rich
UI and the way they've
organized it and basically
trying to extract the
libraries and the patterns out
of it that they're going to
use for Dart.
And so I don't think that
they have anything
today that's concrete.
But I do believe that-- because
Seth Ladd is heavily
involved in interacting with
the community who's
dealing with Dart.
And Seth is a really big fan
of MBC and MBP stuff.
So there probably will be
something that great.
But sorry, I don't
know the answer.
AUDIENCE: That's OK.
Last question, I promise.
When I last looked at Dart,
it said "Alpha" on it.
Do we know when it's going
to be promoted?
RAY CROMWELL: Is Lars
or Vijay here?
Vijay, do you want
to take that?
VIJAY MENON: [INAUDIBLE]
RAY CROMWELL: I'll
just repeat you.
VIJAY MENON: You can get an
official answer from Lars.
[INAUDIBLE]
RAY CROMWELL: Ah.
VIJAY MENON: My understanding
is that later this year,
there'll be more of an official
release, but I'm not
exactly sure we've said
what the date is
going to be on that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RAY CROMWELL: So later this
year, there will be an
official answer.
But if you go talk to Lars,
just track him down--
he's kind of a very tall
guy with glasses--
he could probably give you
a more concrete answer.
But I do believe, at least
from my own personal
experience, the language spec
seems to be settling down very
nicely now.
And so it's probably
going to exit the
Alpha phase very soon.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
RAY CROMWELL: But that shouldn't
dissuade you from
trying it, right?
Have some fun with it.
VIJAY MENON: OK.
Sorry.
Just to add in-- we do have
teams in Google who are
starting to use Dart.
So even though we're still
working on it, it's pretty
usable today.
They wouldn't be using
it if it wasn't.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Are there any legs to the rumor
that GWT is looking for
new intermediate language, and
that intermediate language
might be Dart?
RAY CROMWELL: Yeah, there's
nothing official.
There's been some
talk about that.
I know I've thought about it
personally, of building a Dart
back end for GWT.
So if and when Chrome actually
has the Dart VM built into it,
it might be the case that
either one of two
things might happen.
Either someone might build a
back-end for GWT that emits
Dart code, compiles the Dart,
just to take advantage of the
speed and start-up time
improvements that the Dart VM
will have over V8.
The other option, actually, and
I think this is probably
more likely, is that someone
will build a tool that
actually will help migrate Java
code to Dart in case you
want to basically port
some code over.
There are some difficulties in
compiling GWT code to Dart
because of JavaScript.
So you can imagine, any large
GWT application at sort of the
leaves of the program, deepest
down, is going to have JSNI
method calls to deal
with the browser.
And so those would have to be
replaced with the Dart library
equivalents.
So if someone's calling, like,
dom.getElementById, rather
than making a JSNI call there,
which would have to use this
hack, it would have to replace
it with the equivalent
dart:html library and call
the actual Dart method.
And it's certainly possible to
do that, but it would actually
be a lot of mapping work.
But yeah.
We've talked about it.
If I have nothing
official to say.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Do you think
there's going to--
when they finally get
to release, will
they have the widgets?
And will they be similar to
what GWT has already?
RAY CROMWELL: They
probably will be.
So I don't know, actually, the
timeline on the widgets.
But I know what their philosophy
and intention is.
And so their philosophy and
intention is actually to
deliver widgets that probably
go far beyond what GWT has.
So GWT, when it started,
basically they wanted it to be
more like JavaScript.
We didn't want to be very
opinionated about what the
widgets looked like, so the
first GWT widgets were very
ugly out of the box.
They didn't provide very
much styling at all.
Later, we got some sense
knocked into us, and we
realized most programmers
can't take the time to
actually style all
their widgets.
We should provide some default
that actually looks
reasonable.
And we did that.
But still, it's nothing compared
to what Sencha has,
for example.
Right?
And so that was probably
a mistake
early in the GWT design.
The Dart team, I think, is
eyeing the fact that people
want to design apps and they
want to design them to be
productive, and they want
to wow their consumers.
And so you need not just
a widget library.
You need a very sexy widget
library out of the box.
And so they're actually aiming
to make something that's very
lickable, something that
you're going to
love out of the box.
And it's going to be
very opinionated.
So the slider widget is going
to look the way the Dart
user-interface designer
wants it to look.
And it might not look the way
you want it to look, but it's
probably going to look
really sweet.
And so that's basically what
they're looking at.
Am I summarizing correctly,
Vijay?
OK.
I'm actually not part of the
Dart team, so I don't want to
speak too much about it.
But I overheard some
conversations.
OK?
You have another?
AUDIENCE: Also, I've got a lot
of applications on App Engine.
And is there a pattern or
something that I can use to
migrate it to that?
RAY CROMWELL: You're talking
about App Engine?
AUDIENCE: App Engine using
RequestFactory.
RAY CROMWELL: Oh, yeah.
I actually was going to
discuss this in the
presentation, but I realized
later I had too many slides
and I ran out of time.
But if you're using
RequestFactory, actually--
I should take this offline.
There's an extra bonus.
Because RequestFactory's
JSON-based, it's very possible
to make Dart client code work
with JSON RequestFactory stuff
on the server.
It's not true for GWT-RPC.
GWT-RPC is very tightly tied
in to the Java type system.
RequestFactory isn't.
So actually, it's possible
to make a Dart code call
server-side Java RequestFactory
code.
And so maybe I can catch you
offline and discuss that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So my question would be about
GWT-RPC, so you already
answered it.
So there's some way to
invoke GWT-RPC calls?
RAY CROMWELL: Yes.
That would be kind of difficult
to pull off.
I could see you constructing
something that would invoke
it, but I would see it being
hard to actually deal with the
return value.
So there are Android clients
that actually invoke GWT-RPC
because Android also is Java, so
they can deal with the fact
that when the return value comes
back and it says, like,
it's an array list of doubles or
something, the classes for
decoding an array list of
doubles are already present in
the runtime of Dalvik, right?
With Dart, if you invoke some
server-side call and you get
back an array of things that are
Java types, right, there's
not necessarily something to
map to decode those and
demarshal them into
on the Dart side.
So it's a little
more difficult.
But invoking I could see.
As long as your API actually
uses mostly primitive things,
like longs, and integers, and
strings, and so on, or maybe
POJOs, I think you could
pull it off.
But if you catch me outside, I
might have some suggestions.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
Thanks.
RAY CROMWELL: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
At [INAUDIBLE]
Google our [INAUDIBLE]
we have many talks about Google
Web Toolkit and we have
a separate section in
developers' handbooks about
Google Web Toolkit.
And now it seems [INAUDIBLE]
session, which mentioned
Google Web Toolkit.
So I want to ask,
is GWT is dead?
RAY CROMWELL: No.
I been asked this
question a lot.
And if you look at Google, for
example, a lot of Google's top
properties, actually,
like AdWords--
97% of their revenue comes
from the AdWords team.
And AdWords uses GWT for their
campaign management tool.
And so it's impractical for us
to say that GWT was dead,
first of all.
Second of all, Google
is about choice.
The company's about choice.
You know, App Engine,
for example.
We offer Java.
We offer Go.
We offer Python.
Well, we released Go
recently, right?
Does that mean that Guido van
Rossum is out of a job and
Python is dead?
No.
It just means that there's
another option for developers.
And so what I would say for GWT
is that we're not going to
take GWT away from you.
And we're still going to support
JavaScript development
for V8, and we're still going
to support GWT development.
But we're also offering this new
option that might entice
some people, maybe some people
who don't like JavaScript.
Or maybe they're people who like
JavaScript, but they want
better tools for JavaScript.
They want a really nice
IDE for something
that's a dynamic language.
There's Dart for you.
Or maybe they like Java, but
maybe they're getting tired of
doing enterprise apps.
So nothing's changing
with GWT.
In fact, if you attend my
session on Friday, there is
actually some nice news that's
going to be announced with
respect to GWT's future.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RAY CROMWELL: Anything else?
OK.
Thanks for coming, and--
[APPLAUSE]
RAY CROMWELL: You're welcome.
Be safe on your way down rushing
to get your devices.
Don't trip and fall.